[Music]
my husband hasn't worked now in 10 and a
half months he makes excuses of why he
can't go to work and who's paying bills
are you out working too yes but right
now I'm on maternity are you going to
leave him are you almost done actually
yes I've been strongly considering
[Music]
separation what in the world's going on
this is John with a Dr John delone
show show about your mental and
emotional health your marriage your
dating relationships coming back from
the brink building something new we talk
about kids we talk about schools we talk
about everything on this show been doing
this for two decades sitting with people
when the wheels have absolutely fallen
off their life and the reason I do this
it's cuz I Believe In Hope and I believe
that no matter where you happen to find
yourself tomorrow can look better
and actually tomorrow might be worse and
the day after that might be worse but
over time I believe in the human spirit
because I've seen it over and over and
over again and that means I believe in
you if you want to be on this show I
promise I'll sit with you and we will
figure out at least one next step if you
want to be on this show give me a call
at
33291 or go to John dooney.com
askk while you're at John dooney.com
pick up my number one bestselling book
building a non-anxious life nothing says
I love you for holiday gifts like
handing somebody a book about them
building a non-anxious life I can't
imagine how happy I would be if I opened
the stocking stuffer and I realized that
everyone in my life thought I should
probably work on my emotional and mental
health so it's great marriage marriage
material and uh uh Christmas presents
and don't forget to pick up questions
for humans the new decks for the
holidays I'm going to say save your
holiday
season let's start doing holidays well
we need to like you should make that
your next tattoo let's start doing
holidays
well no all right or you could get
another one called uh Texas Rangers or a
bunch of losers but the see the thing is
that would be a lie oh here we go
because they're not here we go cuz right
now we're up two to one in the World
Series yeah by the time this comes out
Astros on the other hand let's go out to
Philadelphia and talk to Lynn what's up
Lynn
hi Dr John how are you good how are
you I am nervously sweating right now
but I'm okay I'm excited to talk to you
you get the nervous
sweats oh yeah definitely I kind of do
too it's freezing where you are isn't it
it is yeah it's getting cold so there's
no reason to be sweating right now well
especially because I'm not very good at
this but we'll figure it out all right
so how can I help what's
up so my boyfriend told me yesterday
that he found some text messages on my
phone I actually sent you an email last
week saying that I think I've had an
emotional affir with a married cooworker
at my remote job my boyfriend wants to
forgive me and work through this
together so my main question is how do I
Salvage my relationship with my
boyfriend and talk to him about it I
really don't know where to begin or how
I got
here yes so what happened
forget boyfriend forget put boyfriend
over to the side what
happened so I have been with this
company for like three years and I took
a position about a year and a half ago
where I started to work more one-on-one
uh even though it's a completely remote
job I started to have more one-on-one
sessions with my
co-workers and I that's where I met the
cooworker
um and at first he just was really nice
to me and and would send me like funny
memes through like the the platform that
we work through or like send me a song
that he liked or something and um I
thought that it was really just a
friendship which is why I didn't set up
really firm boundaries at the time but
then he started kind of just like
complimenting me a lot telling me that
he thought I was really smart and funny
and kind and and pretty and all these
things and and it was really nice to
hear those things and I just kind of let
myself get swept into it to the point
where I wanted to try and fix things and
and tell my boyfriend about it but I
didn't even know where to begin so
that's kind of where it all started with
that
coworker
so
I most most emotional Affairs happen on
I wish had a different word but on some
kind of Continuum or
Spectrum everything
from this person makes me feel so good
they laugh at my jokes they tell me I'm
beautiful like you they tell me I'm
smart and I'm starting to go to them for
that affirmation when I should be going
to the person I'm exclusive with or the
person I'm
married emotional Affairs can also
have some real intimate like let's talk
let's talk about our spouses or let's
talk about our boyfriends and
girlfriends together or how they just
don't understand but you do right and it
kind of escalates a little bit emotional
Affairs can be um I love you let's meet
up and let's have lunch um emotional
Affairs can some would somewhat and I
don't know how I would I have to sit
down and think this through but I'm just
thinking everything up to physical so we
traded topless pictures we've traded you
know in like stuff that we would never
want someone else to find out so when I
lay it out like that where are
you I it didn't escalate to the point
where it became like sexual it
definitely I would say cross the line of
becoming romantic where I started
opening up about how just being very
vulnerable about things that I shouldn't
have been either like things within my
relationship that I was unhappy about
but also just the fact that I'm unhappy
with where I'm at in life you know at at
my age and at this point in my life I
thought I would be married with kids by
now and and I brought this up to him and
you know he started to kind of say that
I was deserving of those things and that
he wanted to take me on a date and he
wanted to see me in person and just kind
of like affirming those things that I
was opening up about so it didn't cross
the bounds of let's go hook up it was
more like romantic of like I want to
take you on a date and treat you well
and give you all the things that you
want
okay um and I want everyone listening to
get how dicey this how the how slippery
this is right because I would tell you
some of what he told you like if you
were co-workers with me and you were
like man my marriage is a wreck and this
and this I would tell you I want more
for you than that
and then I would
say um I think y'all should go see
somebody and then I would say I really
want I wouldn't say I want to take you
on a date
right I don't know well I say that I
know more people than haven't that have
than haven't have found themselves in
this situation okay so I want you to
know I don't think you're crazy I don't
think you're a terrible person thank you
I think you have a line that you crossed
and I think think that's
important
and let me say this you have a line that
you've crossed I think that
is huge number two not boyfriend's
involved I don't like the way you
started the call because you started the
call with boyfriend found some text I
would love for you from this point
forward to begin to take 100% ownership
of what comes what has happened and what
comes next which is I cross the line
with a coworker others may not see it as
a big deal I didn't hold hands I didn't
make out I didn't send any like topless
photos I didn't do anything like that
but I know I crossed a line to where I
started thinking about this person I
started fantasizing about this person I
started wondering what my life would be
like with
them and I have this this this long-term
boyfriend who thinks you're exclusive
and so whatever the line is I want you
to start that way and then to come
across
uh and then got to deal with boyfriend
so what is it what boyfriend
find
so sorry I'm really nervous um oh you're
okay you're doing
great he found um some texts that were
just on my phone
where basically my coworker was offering
to cook me dinner and inviting me to
come over and he was like Hey you know I
know about this coworker you've told me
about them I didn't know you guys like
change exchange phone numbers and were
having these type of conversations like
it seems really inappropriate and at
that
moment I I know that this sounds bad but
I was waiting until after I talked with
you to be able to talk with him about it
because I didn't even know how to bring
it up so I was I genuinely wanted to
talk to him about it but I wanted to get
some advice first because searching on
the internet you find all sorts of
things you find people telling you to
never talk about it with them and just
pretend like it didn't happen and you
find people telling you that you need to
have them read every single text message
you ever sent and and completely open up
your phone to your boyfriend and I
understand both sides but it got to be
very confusing to what I should do so
when he when he asked me about it I was
honest and I told him when it started
and what but when things crossed the
line and that's when my boyfriend
started asking if he could read the
messages and that was kind of also
another question I wanted to ask you is
do you think that it's helpful to have
him read all those text messages if I
know that what's in them could be
hurtful for
him um I think he gets to decide
that okay because I think
that here's here's the thing going
forward no secrets and I trust you that
when he said hey what in the world's
going on like I knew about this guy and
I knew you thought he was awesome I
didn't now he's offering to like have
you over to his house and make you food
right like that's an invitation for sex
and I want you to come over to my house
and by the way there's people who would
read that Exchange and be like yeah
nothing really happened here I could see
where this could go but nothing really
happened here so that's why what's
important is you saying no no no lines
were
crossed even if we weren't physical I
know where my head was at and I felt so
alive when he asked me to come over and
I actually considered how would I make
this thing happen right you know all
those things I'm going to tell you that
Secrets will kill your relationship
that's number one number two I would ask
him if he was on the phone do you trust
her yes do you trust that nothing
happened physically yes do you trust
that y'all have some things youall have
to work out because this guy was able to
come in and say some things that Lit her
up like a Christmas tree yes I would
probably say do you need to go through
the nitty-gritty details of everything
and some people would say I do I won't
be able to sleep at night without mining
the whole thing and he gets to say that
and you get to decide yay or
nay I would probably tell him ah maybe
maybe not I know um and like me
personally I would I would want to see
every single
thing knowing that it would kill me and
I can name five friends on one hand like
on all five fingers on my right hand
like who would not want to know like no
I don't need to see that I know we got
some stuff we got to deal with and
whatever so I'm gonna go deal with it um
but I trust my wife she says she didn't
do that she didn't do that I trust my
girlfriend she says she didn't do that
she didn't do
that I think we have to sit down and say
you lead the charge again I want to
reiterate I messed up and I think it's
fair to say I didn't hold hands we
didn't kiss I didn't go to his house we
didn't meet secretly like but in my
heart I messed up that's number one
number two I have deleted
everything off social media off my phone
except for the text messages unless he
wants to see them but I don't have a way
to access this person
anymore they are out of my life I've
asked my boss to not be in contact with
him or I've let them know hey we are not
communicating anymore my relationship
with my boyfriend is too important
period very very
clear go ahead yeah um I I also see what
you're saying where you're right I
didn't take accountability at the
beginning and I I feel disgusted with
myself because I don't want to say that
you know this person did make me feel
alive and made me feel special and all
these things because you know I love my
boyfriend he's I love him to death like
he's my family I feel that way about his
family he feels that way about mine I
really he's the only person I've ever
dated that I could see a future with and
that I see him being my future spouse
but but hold on those aren't those
aren't mutually those aren't mutually
exclusive and if you spend time talking
to couples it's
staggering how often something like this
happens somebody has a one night stand
somebody
has they they have an affair and by all
accounts their marriage is great they're
raising kids together they have a home
together they laugh they go on dates
they have a great sex life and then this
other thing happens over here that is
not weird or strange or out of the out
of the norm it doesn't um it blows a
hole in our fantasy that one um that the
perfect marriage means nothing can ever
happen that's not
true and what you're finding out is I
became somebody that I never thought I
would
be and your whole Foundation of who you
are has been shaken
fair fair yeah I mean my dad and my
stepdad both kind of did a similar thing
on my mom where they like basically
cheated with co-workers and I always
said that that wasn't going to be me cuz
I saw the harm that it did to her I
never wanted to be that person okay can
I can
I tell you I honor your anger and
frustration and disgust with yourself
and you could have gone over there
couldn't
you if you had said hey I just got us a
room at the hotel meet me at 9:00
tonight he would have showen up wouldn't
he yeah
yeah and so I also at the same time want
to say you've got a reckon with
you I also want to say but you held the
line both end
okay okay and I also want to acknowledge
and let's just put it out there we're
having the conversation we're already
here it was hard to hold the line wasn't
it yeah I mean a lot of this things that
he was saying were things that I felt
like I was dreaming to hear from someone
and honestly I didn't want to tell my
boyfriend this is what you have to say
to me to make me feel good because that
feels fake that doesn't feel genuine
that feels inauthentic for me to tell
him what you have to say that's a bull
crap Hollywood
Story what your boyfriend has to know is
here's the things that make me feel
alive when you say this when you do do
this then I feel
loved but right now you've been asking
him to read your
mind and he's unable to do
that and slowly you're dying
inside yeah and then a guy who cheats on
his
wife or wants to cheat on his wife and
by the way I hate to tell you this
you're not the only one in his
life but the person who cheats on his
wife happens to know the things to get
somebody fired up
happens to know all the right things to
say I mean I think I partially felt less
guilty about it because he claims to be
like separated from his wife always do
they always
do they always are in the process of
breaking up or we've left each other or
there's always a
thing yeah always a
story and my my boyfriend asked me like
what did I do wrong and it really makes
me feel I feel bad because you should he
really does think this is his fault and
how do I really explain to him that what
happened was not really his fault it was
my own fault I made the decision to
entertain it and to keep the back and
forth going you did and he's gonna he's
an attentive boyfriend who loves his
girlfriend and he is going to have
to uh um wrestle with
that because he's going to want to solve
it and you're going to have to be honest
and open and say what I did what I chose
to do was my doing
and here's what I need moving
forward
and I need you to be very clear about
what you need moving forward to feel
trust to feel safe to feel like I'm all
in okay if that's look at my phone then
that's look at my phone if that is one
of those apps that every text message
that comes in he gets a copy of that
text on his phone too okay we'll do that
for a season okay and if his demands for
what he's going to need are too high you
get to say no and your relationship is
over okay what you can't do is try to
manage what he feels on his side he gets
to own that all of
it but I think it's fair to say this
this situation and by the way I don't
think it was just this guy I think he
happened to be
there I think your earlier comment in at
the beginning of this call was the most
honest thing you've said and that
is I I didn't want to feel like this but
suddenly I found myself feeling like
this I don't think it was him I think it
was any number of men could have filled
that role telling you that you have
value and that you're awesome and you're
hilarious and and you're smart and they
want to spend extra time with you and
they're willing to break the rules of
their marriage and of society to be with
you it made you feel alive
again and so the Reckoning is can we
repair this relationship and rebuild
something new yes you
can boyfriend that I love what do you
need I'm all I'm wide
open and you you have needs in this proc
rebuilding process too sometimes people
overcorrect and they dump everything
what do you need what do you need what
do you need I I I have to pay a Penance
so I get no say in the rebuild and
you're going to find yourself dead again
and this whole thing happens again so if
y'all both choose to rebuild he's
choosing to look at you and say what do
you need to feel alive here and you have
to get over that the that the world
isn't the notebook it isn't some
Hollywood show and you have to say the
the things that you need I need you to
tell me you love me I need you
occasionally to laugh at my jokes even
if they're not that funny
occasionally remind me that I'm smart
and I have value and purpose around here
please will you
occasionally or often help out with the
dishes with the home offer to cook me a
meal you got to be open about those
things and he's probably been squashing
some things too it wouldn't surprise me
if he felt a little bit
dead dead inside also he gets to say all
right while we're here right this is a
rebuild this isn't a let's get back to
the way things were the way things were
is over now and you are going to have to
work to trust you again because you saw
your dad do it and you saw your stepdad
do it and then you found yourself right
on the edge leaning
over and again I want to end this call
with
this you held the
line you
crossed you know you fell for somebody
you had a crush on somebody you had
feelings for somebody
fair but you held the line and I'm proud
of you for that because that's
hard tonight you sit down with boyfriend
and say I messed
up I want to rebuild this whole thing
from the floor up what are you going to
need and here's what I'm going to
need I'm in if you're in and by the way
all of this starts with you looking him
in the eye and say I will never contact
that person again and I will never
receive contact from that person again
period thank you so much for the call I
know this is scary and you um pretty
brave and millions and millions and
millions and millions of Americans are
experiencing this exact thing or have
it's
hard and I promise there's healing on on
the other side if you both are in
you're awesome Lynn we'll be right
back hey good folks delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice ice is hallow
hallow is the number one Prayer app in
the world and they're giving you three
free months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling Hall makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Hall is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com dealone today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hall.com
delone for 90 days
free all right we're back let's go out
to the home of the greatest food on
planet Earth San Antonio Texas and talk
to Sarah what's up
Sarah hi Dr joh how are you I'm hanging
in there how are you about the same oh
boy so what's
up um so I I need some help I'm I'm very
exhausted and overwhelmed handing
handling a situation with my husband and
my 15-year-old son uh oh it's two
separate
situations um let's start with husband
husband okay um my husband hasn't worked
now in 10 and a half
months and I he got fired um from his
job and I I don't know he makes excuses
of why he can't go to work why he
doesn't try to to find a job it's he
gets too distracted there's too many
things
do um this then it's just one excuse
after
another I don't know what have you how
has that gone in your home I mean who's
paying bills are you out working
too yes but right now I'm on maternity
um I've been out since the end of August
so you have a 15-year-old and an
infant there's actually four kids 15 13
we're a blended family okay um those two
kids are from my previous marriage and
then we have two kids a 2-year-old and
then a newborn good God so what does he
do all
day um sometimes he sleeps he sleeps for
hours he's got a lot of mental health
issues going on uhhuh sounds like he's
struggling yes and um he'll get
distracted busy himself with
straightening things I'm containers
filling
containers um so let me ask let me ask
you this I have a hard hard question to
ask just to kind of cut to the chase
sure are you going to leave him are you
almost
done I actually yes I've been strongly
considering separation
okay when you've been facing this for a
year um 10 months right you're basically
been doing this for a year um you have
to have in mind your or what
conversation and what I mean by your or
what conversation is you sit down and
say you have to go see a doctor or a
psychologist or a counselor within the
next seven days or I'm moving
out you have to go get a job and begin
going to the job every
day and we've had by the way the
greatest run of job opportunities in
American history the last 36 months 24
months he can get a job tomorrow he can
get a job today he can get two jobs
today and actually depending on what his
what his mental health diagnostic is who
knows what he's going through if he's
got depression disorder if he's got who
knows but often getting up and getting a
job is helpful it gives you a thing to
go towards it gives you a purpose a role
it gives you meaning right not every
situation that's why it needs to go see
somebody but you have to have a very
firm or
what because you've been him hauling and
hinting at this and getting mad at him
for 10 months now right right what did
he get fired
for
stealing what was he
stealing money and gift
cards well that might make it hard to
get a
job jeez
Louise
yeah what was his response to getting
caught and get
fired um
he he was very I wouldn't say remorseful
I think he was more panicked that he got
caught and and
shocked is that the kind of guy he
is no well not the kind of guy that I
thought he was we've been married since
2019 um no I really I was shocked when I
found out that he was stealing um that's
not the husband that I know that wasn't
in his character however later def find
out he was fired from two other jobs for
stealing and I did not know that oh well
gez hey Sarah lead with that next time
okay lead with that yeah so you're
married to somebody who is a crook who
steals and is constantly fired from his
job
repeatedly
Fair
this is not a fair question but I have
to ask it why did you go through and
have kid number
four um he so I found out I was pregnant
one week before he was fired oh jeez I'm
so sorry I'm happy that your baby's
coming I hope your baby's healthy and
wonderful and all that's great and I can
just imagine how much this complicates
things yeah what is your plan
plan if you moved out tomorrow what
would your plan be where would you
go um
so what I would want I've been working
with a counselor I would want him to
move out okay we're in a three-bedroom
apartment we had a house we had to sell
the house when he lost his job and
wouldn't work and I would want him out
and the kids and I stay in the apartment
can you afford that when I go back to
work yes it'll be tight but yes okay the
research tells me unfortunately that
when somebody has to leave their husband
for any number of reasons the husband's
net worth goes up a little bit and her
net worth goes down somewhat
significantly especially in the short
term yeah so I want to make sure you
have an ironclad
plan right and I don't right now that's
what I'm trying to work on that's why I
haven't done
anything I need you to I need you to
stop trying to work on this and I need
you to get very tactical very quick okay
do you have somebody in your life you
could have that conversation
with yes a counselor okay also at the
end of this call I want you to hang on
I'm going to give you a couple of free
financial coaching calls with the team
at Ramsey Solutions okay and they will
help you build a budget that is based on
real numbers and real
life okay okay thank
you but practicing with your counselor
is really smart and next time you go to
your counselor I want you to say these
words I'm ready to practice my final
conversation and they can help you write
it they can help you script it they can
help you speak it out loud feel it in
your body so that when you actually sit
down across from your husband and you
lay it out there um you have rehearsed
it okay okay
now well let me just say this I'm sorry
this isn't how it's supposed to
be the guy you married and have kids
with is not supposed to be secretly
stealing from his business and then you
find out he's been doing it for
years husbands are not supposed to get
fir and then sit around for 10 months
people get fired life happens people get
laid off that happens that's life but
you don't get to sit around for 10
months while your pregnant wife is
working up until the day she has a baby
I'm sorry that's not supposed to be how
that is he's supposed to be out there
with four jobs and he's going to be very
hard to hire right now because he's been
dishonest so many
times but he can get a job mowing lawns
and he can get a job delivering for Uber
and he can get a job delivering pizzas
and he can get a job at a dog grooming
place he could figure it out he's
choosing he can get a job with all the
building that's going on in San Antonio
he can get a job on a
site but he's choosing not to and he can
go deal with his mental health
challenges and he's choosing not
to yeah are you safe
Sarah um yes Why the
pause
sorry it's
okay he's been getting more
Angry um verbally abusive towards me and
the kids um yeah a few weeks ago he left
my son stranded he kicked him out of the
car he was mad with his attitude
um how old is your son
15 he's watching his dad constantly get
fired for
uh be for being dishonest and then he's
watching his dad lay around the
house of course he's a 15-year-old with
an attitude he's watching his pregnant
mom float the whole family of course he
has an
attitude
yeah do you have family in the area
Sarah
no my husband has family and they're all
um rather supportive and talking to me
of trying to figure out what to do what
what does that mean they're supportive
of him or they're supportive of you they
know he's a he's a dead
beat um they're supportive of me
okay what I like to look at in these
situations is trend lines escalation
lines and this seems to be trending in
the very right wrong
direction it sounds like as you're
getting closer and closer to going back
to work and he is out longer and
longer he's getting angrier and angrier
and less safe and less safe true or
false
true I I missed that true
okay so how much longer are you going to
wait
that's the question that I can't figure
out you need to make a call
now I keep waiting and waiting it's not
going to happen you've waited a year and
now your kids are paying the price how
long are you going to
wait yeah because you're worth more than
this and you know that they're worth
more than this and you know that he's
worth more than this for God's
sake
how much
longer
yeah do you think is a 30day time
frame to give him an ultimatum to have
full-time
employment within 30 days is appropriate
inappropriate too much too little what
what is your input um I think he needs
to be separated from you guys
immediately based on leaving a
15-year-old on the side of the
road because what that shows me is that
he is
emotionally either very very
immature or he is struggling profoundly
emotionally to the point that he can't
be in the presence of minor children
because he's letting his inability to
control himself as the adult in the room
or in the
car be managed by a child and that's not
your 15-year-old's job your
15-year-old's job is to push boundar and
to figure how the world works it's Dad's
job to act like Dad and to be the firm
responsible adult and that interaction
and he is unable to do that right
now I don't mind 30-day separations or
ultimatums I think those are can be very
wise sometimes but they have to have
ground rules to them here's the
date we will reconvene in 30 days at
this restaurant at this time and by that
time you will show me you have 3 to four
weeks of weekly counseling you will show
me that you have full-time employment at
at least two places and you will show me
your first pay
St and in the meantime I'm going to meet
with an attorney to begin drawing up
separation
papers
okay and that means he's got to find a
place to live that means he's got to get
real responsible real
fast
based on what you're telling me I don't
think he can make it but I do understand
your heart and not wanting to be a
single mom with four kids over like
suddenly
right yeah I get
that real quick what's your challenge
with your
15-year-old my 15-year-old um he's been
vaping yeah you know why because it
works
that's what he says yeah I don't blame
that 15-year-old one second it's dumb
and it's going to make him sick but good
God I don't blame that kid for a second
I'm glad that's all he's
doing it's probably not all he's doing
by the way but I'm
glad yeah he's been in therapy for a few
years um he and he has a plan with his
counselor he he wants to quit by the
beginning of the New Year's what he says
he wants to quit vaping yeah okay give
him give him an environment where his
body will let him
rest yeah needs peace he needs
peace anytime a 15-year-old heads into
any sort of substance use a it it's uh
it's a it feels good right it's just
different it's sensation and kids seek
sensation I got no problem with with I I
understand it right it's the adult's job
to make sure they don't get their hands
on that stuff and it's the adult's job
to talk it through and it's the adult's
job to play defense I'm not ever going
to get mad at a 14-year-old for wanting
to feel like a buzz to what it feels
like to smoke a cigarette or to feel
like a dip or to feel like
whatever but in this
situation I get it completely cuz he's
got to figure out out some
way to bring his body down because his
body's at War
right yeah
yeah and by the way when you kick Dad
out you're going to be the bad guy for a
season you got to make peace with
that with your 15-year-old you're
playing a long game with
him because he sees himself in his
father
right dead
it he's your kid that's
stepdad right where's his where's his
biod dad here in the same town but
they're estranged okay he sees himself
in his
dad and he knows part of me is that
guy that haunts him and the next example
of a man he has is his
stepdad who is so out of control he
dropped a 15-year-old off on the side of
the
road and the other half of him is his
mom who he's watching hold the whole
house
up but that boy you're right that boy
needs peace you need peace Sarah your
whole household does here's what I want
you to do I want you to call your
counselor and say I'm ready to make a
30-day
plan I want you to Google Terry reel I
just mentioned this in a in a recent
episode Terry real.com or Terren
real.com t r r y and I want you to
Google the 10 rules of a separation of a
trial separation it will pop up and he's
got the 10 rules I want you to print
that off and take that with your
counselor and I want you to map it
out but I never am in the business of of
making this call you've decided you want
to do this I am in the business of
protecting kids
especially I think the time is now and I
want yall to get this thing practiced
get this thing done and have that
conversation with husband
ASAP he needs help you need help and you
need some clarity and hang on the line
I'm going to hook you up with those
financial coaches I know that it's super
easy to be like you need to go it's time
there's a fiscal reality especially for
what's about to be single moms it's
harder than just you need to move on out
and Empower yourself okay cool but I
can't send empowerment certificates to
the to the lighting company right so
we're gonna help you make a plan a road
map financially right with the Ramsey
Financial coaches so hang on the line
also I'm going to send you the every
dollar app I'm going to send you FPU for
a year okay that's going to be my gift
to you to give you some sort of plan to
follow financially after this whole mess
is over because there's going to be a
very significant fiscal reality to a
three-bedroom apartment in San Antonio
and four kids and one income
that's going to be tough tough tough
tough and you're worth it and you might
have to end up moving you might have to
make some calls for some support and
help in the interim you are worth it
thank you for the call call
anytime if husband wants to call I'd
love to talk to him too we'll be right
back hey delone here good folks our
society has devalued sleep we're told to
keep working and grow rinding through
the fatigue and pretend that we don't
need sleep then this crazy culture tries
to shame us when we do hit the sack at a
normal time I'm here to tell you 7 to9
hours of refreshing sleep is essential
for all aspects of your physical and
mental health and to help with that I
recommend investing in an amazing
mattress getting great sleep is
priceless but a premium mattress can
cost a lot and that's a big reason why I
love dreamcloud dreamcloud mattresses
are made with premium materials for half
the cost of other premium mattresses
they use Advanced Technologies to keep
you comfortable all night for a great
price and the exclusive deal they're
offering my listeners can help even more
right now dreamcloud is offering my
listeners 40% off all mattresses plus an
additional $50 discount go to dreamcloud
sleep.com and enter code John deloney
today that's dreamcloud sleep.com with
code John deloney
all right we're back let's go out to
Idaho and talk to Ryan what's up
Ryan how we doing partying dude what are
you up
to just living another living another
day there you go it's better than the
alternative what's up man yeah Mar sure
so my question for you is how do I know
when I need to put my
family and or my wife on the back burner
for a season
um family's easier wife is another story
what's going on right so over the last
few years you know I've I mean I'm not I
shouldn't say I'm not much of a social
person because I am but just lately I've
been kind of wanting to start dreaming
and start doing
more and but I got you know like family
members and or my wife they're like no
you you don't want to do that you're
going to want to do this or you don't
want to go there you're going to want to
come here give me an example of what
you're talking about so like being debt
free um a year ago I took a weekend for
myself to really try to figure out what
I wanted to do and how I wanted to do it
because I was tired of I'm tired of
living paycheck to paycheck um back in
2015 I or back at the end of 2014 I was
debt-free completely I was just like all
right I'm going to go I'm going to get
into my career I'm going to do the
things that I want to do do and just
make a great life out of it um you know
and I was in discussion with my mom and
my mom's just like well you're single so
you know date a girl for a year you know
and see where that thing goes and then
you know after a year or whatever you
know you guys get married well in early
2015 I met a girl we had a great time
met her family and within three months
of knowing each other four months of
knowing each other we are engaged in by
June we were you know June of that year
we were married okay things for great I
was living life you know things were
going well and then all of a sudden you
know I mean we have a good relationship
between each other um which is you know
it's not that's not the bad thing it's
just that our my debt-free status went
from 100% to hey we need to go to the
store and buy this we need to go to the
store and buy that we need to do this or
we need to do that and I you know okay
you're right you know happy wife happy
life that's stupid
advice right and so I mean and so and
the years have gone by but with just
within the last
year I've really gotten tired of living
paycheck to paycheck and having that
status on me and I was so happy and then
you know I got your uh own your past
change your future book and I was just I
mean that book like literally woke me up
I'm like all right I'm going to do this
I'm going to go here these are the plans
I'm going to make you know I'm going to
include the wife and you know include my
family and show them you know what this
is all about and I get kind
of well I mean it was great then but
maybe not now or let's just do this or
let's just do that let me let me cut let
me cut you off number one your family's
out of the picture they don't get a vote
okay how old are you I'm
40 and I think I mean let just so let me
for that reason it's for a long time I'm
the I I'm the middle child child in my
family I am too and for the longest time
and for the longest time my family's
always put me on the back bur or told me
you know let's not do this or let's not
do that kind of why do you keep asking
your
family because I I want their approval I
guess okay that's on you quit blaming
them right you keep going to them and
they keep giving you advice that's
killing you it's suffocating you and
you're mad at
them yeah why don't give them that they
don't get that power look dude I love my
dad he's amazing and I love my mom she's
incredible my great great grandkids will
talk about those two right and I didn't
ask him about moving to Nashville I
didn't ask him about becoming the Dena
students at a law school I didn't ask
him about the job before that you know
why they don't get a vote it's my
job yes right right I did ask my wife
right and and let me tell you this my
conversation with my wife had very
little to do with I want to do this job
over that
job it had to do with I'm
dying or her more specifically saying
I'm watching my husband
die right is there something else you
can
do and that is very different than I
want a status of being debt-free I could
give a crap about any status of any kind
what I want is
freedom and part of
Freedom part of this idea that I can
kind of do what I want within the bounds
of the law part of that is because I
don't owe anybody any money right but I
don't want the status of debt free yeah
similar I wanted to write a good book I
wanted actually I didn't even I didn't
care that about that as much as I want
people to have more peaceful lives and
I'm sick of the the mental health
narrative that's out there and so right
I have a show so I wrote a book and when
I sat down to write a book I decided I
want to write a good book and I wanted
it man it made me feel good when I got
the
call from the the text message from Dave
Ramsey telling me dude your book just
went number one that was awesome right
and that's not a status I was trying to
get you know why because that status
lasts about 30 seconds
mhm but having people all over the
country say and all over the world
actually say dude I had a conversation
with my wife that I've never had right
I'm going to counseling for that that's
awesome but my guess is you've never sat
down with your wife and said honey I
can't
breathe and I I I and I'll be honest
with you I have tried and she's just
like well maybe we need to do this
differently or maybe we need to do that
differently and I'm like okay let's do
it but then like I you know I mean like
for example a year ago I took a weekend
to myself to really kind of just you
know okay this you know kind of make a
plan took the weekend I came back and I
sat down with my wife and I said look
this is need this needs to change and
this needs to change and she just kind
of okay and nothing's changed well and
so to this point what what did you tell
her needed to change I just said that I
just we need to be a little bit more you
know we need to get on a budget we need
need to okay that's where you went wrong
work together you disappeared for a
weekend and you came back with a plan
for
her true when you go away for a weekend
I come back and I just did
this I didn't take a full weekend but I
got away for a day after basically being
out of pocket for a year writing a book
selling a book being on the road being
all over the place and I got super sick
and I was out laid out for a week and
then I had an event and then I was
immediately back on the road I took a
day right and then I circled back and
you know what I told my
wife here's what I need to do moving
forward for this upcoming
season okay and that way she didn't have
to fight me because I didn't look at her
and say you're going to need to start
doing this this this and this right see
the difference yeah I
do you my friend have to take some
ownership okay and that might look like
honey I refuse I'm just not going to
borrow money anymore because I can't
breathe okay if you choose to borrow
money we need to have deeper
conversations about our marriage because
whenever I
say I can't breathe and you say well I'm
going to buy this
anyway it feels like that thing you're
buying has more value to me than I do
more value to you than I do right every
bit of that conversation is not about
what she's doing it's about how you
feel those are two different things see
what I'm saying right yeah but your
parents stop asking
them right and if they say hey man why
are you hey Mom Dad I'm 40 I got to
start making some of these calls on my
own I appreciate youall I love
you right you know um right I bought
your your newest book and you know one
that bundle and when I saw that video I
mean I've watched that video constantly
which one and that that uh thing you
give I gave that you talked about oh
gotcha gotcha the four things choosing
Freedom yeah yeah um and I shared that
with my mom and you know I sent it to
her and I said hey you got to watch it
well about a month later she we we were
on the phone and she's just like I can't
believe
it I said what she's like you you were
totally right and I said what do you
mean she goes like I've had to watch I
mean I've listened to that thing and
I've watched that thing like a dozen or
so times now and I was just like it's
that's what's changing this whole
attitude of my life that's changing my
direction and she goes well I I will
approve of anything you want to do
because you know that's she doesn't get
your
approval right no no I mean I'm not
saying the approval I'm just saying the
fact that headed that way whether you
like it or not kind of a thing and she
goes you needed to do this a long time
ago and I was just like well of course I
did awesome kind of a thing good but it
was just it was great to hear that my
mom's just like I have to listen to that
thing over and over again because you
know what I don't have to have everybody
at the house you know I don't have to
and you know she's on her own adventure
dude if she comes to you in 6 months or
a year and says hey I see you're glowing
I see you laugh a lot more I see every
time we go to dinner now you pick up the
check and you pay for it in
cash I see you saying hey we're not
going to be able to do H holidays this
year or we're only buying one gift a
person everybody make
peace because that's what we're
doing I had that by the way I had that
conversation with my son this morning
for breakfast I'm recording this show on
a Tuesday I had that that conversation
this morning hey by the way son this
year we're just going to do two nice
things and I've already got them we're
going to do a couple of neat like
adventures and that's going to be
Christmas and he smiled and goes you
said that the last two years and I go I
know but this year I'm being for real
and he goes that sounds great but I had
that conversation with my son today you
know why he didn't get a vote he doesn't
get a
vote but his mom
does yes it probably felt it probably
felt validated and you felt Vindicated
when your mom said man you were right we
should have done this a long time
ago she doesn't get a vote when she's
telling you you you don't want to do
that she also doesn't get a vote when
she tells you oh you're so right son
because you're still going to her for
approval it's
cool but dude you got to stop seeking
your mom's approval you're 40 you have
to decide how do I want my house to feel
when I walk
in what am I going to take ownership I'm
going to take ownership of how I feel in
my thoughts and my actions period honey
I can't ever borrow another dollar
again and if you
do I'm going to feel like the image that
you're trying to hold up is more
important than me being able to sleep
all night or be intimate with you or to
be at peace with our kids or whatever's
going
on will you walk this with
me hang on the line I'm going to send
you Financial Peace University I'm going
to send you the courses the nine week
the nine lessons here's what I want you
to do here's my Challenge and I'm in one
of those lessons or maybe two of those
lessons here's my challenge I want you
to ask her would you be willing to watch
these videos with me just be willing to
watch them with
me it would mean the world to me if you
did
that give that a shot and here's the
deal she might say no and if she says no
your marriage is in bigger trouble than
you think it is cuz youall need have
that conversation that something of
super value super importance she's like
nah I'd rather have a
Suburban i' rather have a suburban and a
dead
husband than a used whatever and a
husband who laughs a lot and is full of
joy and has retirement and doesn't owe
anybody any money I'd rather I'd rather
the shiny thing now thanks though y'all
got bigger issues bigger fish to fry my
guess
is my super guest is
Ryan she's sick of playing second to
your mom at
40 if you start the conversation with I
have been hanging on to my mom and dad's
approval for so long I'm done with it
from this point forward it's just you
and me she might just melt into a puddle
on the
floor I'd start there thanks for the
call my brother we'll be right
[Music]
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at john.com
all right as we wrap up today's show we
have a studio audience and we have
a am I the problem it's me question go
for it Kelly all right I'm GNA look out
to you guys for approval thumbs up or
thumbs down okay all right uh this
lady's name she just goes by GD I want
to give my husband an ultimatum we buy a
house in the summer of 2024 or we don't
go overseas to see his family in
Pakistan that November so November 2024
for context we have put off buying a
home in our own of Our Own in the US in
order to help his family overseas to
build their own home pay for his mom's
cancer treatment his brother's wedding
all in cash he also sends money every
month to his dad for his expenses we
have one boy and another one on the way
we currently live in an apartment
complex that has pests and rodents for
over a year so there's some urgency to
improve our living conditions I feel
like our family has been compromised
enough for his family's needs and and I
need to put my foot down am I the
problem yikes this one's
tough this what's tough nobody raise
your thumbs up or down out there um so
here's the thinking through there's
cultural challenges here there's family
challenges here there's reality
challenges on the ground
here H okay tell me if I'm crazy Kelly
I'm looking at
you this is a question about a house but
it's not oh yeah so much more than that
this is a question about family values
cultural values and what kind of Life
are we going to build and this probably
should have been a conversation that was
had explicitly before you got married
it's very very very common that people
move to the US and send money all over
the world to take care of
family wedd I can sit here and go a
wedding I'm not paying for my brother's
wedding before I give my wife a
house and I also know weddings have
different um weight in other cultures in
other countries I get that too so I
can't speak to what life is like in
Pakistan mom's cancer treatment I would
probably hold off buying a house and
help take care of my mom right I get all
that
and you got one kid another one on the
way your wife needs a home right so for
me it's less about putting my put down
and more about we need to have a
conversation about what kind of family
we're going to have cuz I need to know
now is all of our money going to
continue
to go away because if it does I got to
make some choices about our
marriage if not
um I don't know it's just this one's
messy I think it's very easy for me as
an American cityan to be like NOP either
or and you're I'm out of here I think
it's more complicated than that yeah um
I think maybe there's a compromise
somewhere in here clearly they need to
get out of where they are correct if
there's you know rats and there's bugs
you don't want to bring children into
that so maybe there's a compromise of
hey let's we're going to rent a house
correct for now and for a year two years
whatever and we're going to put some
kind of time limit on how long we're
sending this money over or whatever just
but like you said it's a conversation
that's clearly not happening correct so
I don't think she's the problem or not
the problem I think it's they're not
talking yes and I want to hold space for
culturally he may not give a crap what
she thinks it might just be I'm doing
whatever I'm doing this what we're doing
right and she's got to make that call
for herself yeah um or he may be
thinking he's being the greatest husband
and son in the world by taking good care
of his family and has no idea that she's
drowning I doubt that but usually when
you get to ultimatums I say that I say
people get to ultimatums and they they
make the call but that's not always true
sometimes people get to ultimatums and
they never spoke their needs out loud
um I don't think after supporting
everybody sending money every month all
that I don't think this is the moment in
history to take a humongous family trip
that's going to cost 10,000 or 15,000 or
20,000 bucks it maybe it's time to get
moved out and rent a house or buy a
condo or something
um but yeah it doesn't sound like we're
at ultimatum yet it sounds like we're at
really hard direct conversation and
that's before ultimatum when he says I'm
not listening to a stupid thing you say
I'm going to do this this is my money
I'm sitting at overseas to take care of
my family then you get to ultimatum but
I still think we have to have an open
direct honest needs conversation that
sound fair yeah 100% I think that too
that she needs to say exactly first what
she feels how she feels and then put the
ball in his court and maybe it's I'm not
living in this apartment right for
another 60 days yeah we'd like you to
come with us yes I would love for you to
be in our new place with us yeah um and
I know there's a there's a Financial sit
I mean I know there's a lot of realities
to this that are just messy but have the
direct needs conversation and then the
ultimatums come after that be clear
clear as kind clear as kind clear as
kind no secrets love you guys
bye